thanks so much for for joining me former
prime minister um
in terms of
where things stand at the moment this
latest attack uh aside there's been a
bit of a pause what's your assessment of
the of the state of the war and
the time frame from here
i think mr putin continued to
getting
producing some kind of victories to to
to report to people of russia
which is under
majority of them and the foolish
propaganda and they absolutely lost the
reality uh and then in fact just i think
just the the enlarged occupation of the
territory of donbass which uh i think mr
putin is the the prime the the prime
goal is and then of course to keep this
land corridor which mr putin already
created between crimea and donbass and
the the the city of herzone and part of
herzone region that's already under
putin's occupation occupation i think
that would be some kind of middle
goal for mr putin to achieve and to
announce victory he needs victory and he
needs to report to people of russia that
uh the operation as he said just
completed and they achieved something
and he believes that the west would face
with the political fatigue
and that would the situation as it is
now i mean just the level or territory
of occupation would stay for a few years
and after that just mr putin will
continue to have his aggression on other
or the same direction that will be
future
in terms of uh as you mentioned there
his commitment is is one thing what
about the time he has to maintain that
commitment to domestically is he under
pressure uh in any way shape or form or
not
i think yes this coming autumn that will
that will be the the the point when
everything i would say some kind of
new questions
and people's mind would appear on
ordinary people and they will start to
start asking asking this question and
the propaganda will not be able to
provide appropriate answers mr putin
needs victory he needs to report victory
he needs to to be seen strong
not defeated but strong as uh with the
the victorious result and of course just
those supplies of heavy weapons to
ukraine and this uh i would say on the
large-scale operations by the ukrainian
army using this new equipment of course
demonstrates that ukrainian army could
come soon i believe to the level
comparable i mean from the military
point of view comparable with the
putin's army that will be i would say
the turning point i think that what
could come after the training of
ukrainian militaries it could come such
a situation could appear just in october
november i guess uh one other thing that
could come in october november would be
uh russia cutting off gas supplies uh to
europe as the temperature drops do you
expect him to employ that tactic or
almost quite the opposite is he fighting
to keep that uh revenue stream coming in
i think that's that's absolutely
absolutely possible
in fact and in fact i guess right now mr
putin technically technologically is not
prepared to cut the gas supply right now
but of course his this arm this weapon
he gets in his hands and in fact he
couldn't stop just exploration of
natural gas but
could could prepare that's why he's
looking for another supplies to
china and that's what that's what they
are doing right now but uh of course
this weapon exists and uh
and the the the cash uh foreign exchange
in flor out of selling of oil and gas uh
of course is reducing but mr putin
cannot use this because of the sanctions
and they accumulated on the accounts on
the gas prom bank and uh
there is no demand for foreign exchange
in russia because just all supplies of
all
of all exports to russia and all
purchases of those goods just stopped
and that's why just the the exchange
rate of ruble is
is quite strange and people don't
understand what's happened why why the
currency rubles are appreciated so
heavily
while while inflation is high and the
gdp go for
the phase falls down just uh the economy
is squeezing right now but
the currency is appreciated that is um
the strange situation
in fact uh central bank continues to
apply some kind of market policy while
just the government produces completely
different that's what they have to
settle something just and i mean in
terms of policy whether they go in the
same way or just
get accept the total isolation and
create other instruments of keeping
economy so but i mean let's explore that
a little bit further i mean how how much
is the russian economy
suffering at the moment even if there
are some public signs like the currency
that might suggest otherwise uh things
uh on a breaking point is is putin about
to face riots or or is that still some
way away
uh i think uh there is no known uh
expectation for rice in the in the
upcoming future and the foreseeable
future but of course
in the future in general of course it
could be the case but uh in fact just
inflation is high
20 just as an international methodology
but for this overall inflation but if
you pick up just four points for for
goods and services for instance medicine
food staff
communal services and transportation you
will get inflation like 50 that is half
of population or even more just spending
may have this expenditure only on these
directions for them inflation is very
very high that's why i'm saying by
autumn just the negativism or a negative
attitude to the whole situation will
increase that's why putin needs victory
to report that he already achieved
something and this the west's already
just faced with the political fatigue
and it's not going to to
to ex
provide more and more billions to
ukraine to keep this war
for exhausting uh the that's why i think
just this will be expectation just i
hope
and i feel this coming autumn would
change the whole situation because of
different reasons uh the sanctions six
packages of sanctions would would bring
a first negative result and and of
course economists will report that um
gdp lost 10 percent of gdp
and inflation is very high and secondly
just ukrainian army would start having
just more successful operations on the
battlefield
in terms of the nuances of russian
politics in the short term
talk us through the significance of of
what's gone on recently that even though
parliament was in recess uh president
putin's called for a special
session what's going on there
as a special session is nothing's uh
nothing special special session just to
finalize just the
the spring session i think just and to
adopt those laws which they started to
consider
but in fact
if something extraordinary and necessary
is necessary for mr putin he will call
them immediately but
i don't think just lower house with duma
is named important for him on this
operation he needs permission from the
upper chamber but he already got all
permissions for this war and that's why
he doesn't need anything just i don't
think that mr penis prepares some kind
of so just statement for mobilization or
for army for instance i completely
exclude this because it will be it will
be demonstration that the demonstration
of his weakness that means just
his military operation as he calls this
um it means unsuccessful that's he
calling for the whole war full-scale war
which he
just doesn't want to
announce as a war but
that's what i'm saying just the the they
already are facing with the problems of
to mobilize
mobilization of uh on a voluntary basis
uh
yeah
i'm sorry former prime minister just
just to round things off because we're
nearly out of time uh just wondering how
you think all of this ends uh
particularly on on your side on the
russian side and for president putin and
a reminder of course to our viewers that
that you served as his prime minister
though early in his term 2000 to 2004
and have since uh taken a position
against him
yes i thought with putin who was
completely different putin at that time
putting those supportive reforms of my
cabinet right now we can just
use a contrary policy absolutely
contrary to all those values just i i'm
devoted to
and that's the the end we all believe
that
ukraine would defend and would announce
victory soon uh sooner in few months i
hope uh that they defended their
territory and would start uh obviously i
would start uh liberalization and with
the uh would get
installed
territorial integrity and putin should
be seen as defeated in these cages the
the changes politically changes will
start in russia and the inner circle
would start reconsidering contribute to
him and those people who support people
who support putin now they will start
reconsidering the whole attitude to the
war
first of all and secondly to put him
himself and that's and they will start
calling for changes i hope that process
will start in a few months of course it
will not be overnight but uh the the
beginning would
could bring fruit uh the the desirable
fruit and
and i would say one year or a year and a
half i think just changes in russia are
inevitable as soon as as putin is
defeated in ukraine
so it's possible that vladimir putin in
some way or another is out of office in
russia uh within 12 months
uh i don't exclude this yes i don't
it's absolutely is directs direct
connection with the results of this war
with ukraine if ukraine wins
or just protect itself it means just at
the beginning of the end of queen's era